Olá amigos do canal hoje eu trago um
alerta importante para sua saúde algumas
frutas apesar de saudáveis a primeira
vista podem ser vilãs para quem sofre de
gordura no fígado sim é surpreendente
mas infelizmente é verdadeiro se você
sofre dessa condição de saúde que pode
destruir o seu fígado Este vídeo é
essencial para você eu vou compartilhar
as sete piores frutas para gordura no
fígado E por que que você deve pensar
duas vezes antes de incluir em sua dieta
se estiver lidando com essa situação
Além disso eu vou compartilhar as frutas
amigas do seu fígado fique comigo porque
essas informações podem fazer uma grande
diferença na sua saúde pessoal o que é
Afinal a gordura no fígado a doença
hepática gordurosa não alcoólica também
conhecida como esteatose hepática já
atinge mais de 30% dos brasileiros e
representa atualmente uma epidemia
Global esta condição ocorre quando há um
acúmulo excessivo de gordura nas células
do fígado agora aqui vem um fato que
pode surpreender muitos de vocês a
gordura no fígado não é causada
principalmente pelo consumo de gordura é
isso mesmo embora pareça contraditório o
principal vilão aqui é outro na verdade
a gordura no fígado tem uma relação
Direta com a resistência à insulina e o
diabetes e aqui está o ponto crucial a
principal causa dessa condição é o
consumo de produtos ricos e carboidratos
como pães aquela cerveja com milho e
também os açúcares especialmente a
frutose estou falando não apenas da
frutos encontrada naturalmente nas
frutas mas especialmente naquela
adicionada artificialmente presente em
sucos
industrializados refrigerantes e outros
alimentos processados pessoal a frutose
é processada pelo fígado e ela se
transforma em gordura com muita
facilidade nesse órgão se consumida em
grandes quantidades pode levar a gordura
no fígado e outras doenças então o que
que é exatamente a resistência a
insulina E por que que ela é tão
perigosa a resistência a insulina ocorre
quando as células do nosso corpo não
responde adequadamente a insulina o
hormônio responsável por regular o nível
de açúcar no sangue isso pode levar a um
aumento dos níveis de açúcar no sangue e
eventualmente ao pré-diabetes diabetes
além disso a resistência insulina está
associada a uma variedade de outras
condições de saúde incluindo doenças
cardíacas a gordura no fígado é
considerada uma manifestação hepática da
síndrome metabólica composta por
obesidade ou sobrepeso pré-diabetes ou
diabetes hipertensão e alterações de
colesterol e você é novo por aqui clique
em inscrever-se entre pra nossa toma
saudável curtir o vídeo dê o seu joinha
e não guarde essas dicas só para você
compartilhe com seus familiares e amigos
no WhatsApp espare nas redes sociais
saúde informação de qualidade antes de
mergulharmos na lista das sete frutas é
essencial destacar um ponto bem
importante o foco da nossa atenção hoje
não é simplesmente o consumo das frutas
em si mas sim a maneira como consumimos
para aqueles que estão lidando com a
gordura no fígado é fundamental prestar
atenção especial ao consumo de sucos
feitos dessas frutas e ao consumo
exagerado das próprias frutas é
importante entender que não estamos
dizendo que você não pode desfrutar
dessas frutas pelo contrário frutas são
uma parte valiosa de uma dieta saudável
no entanto para quem já tem gordura no
fígado a moderação é muito importante e
Aqui vai um conselho valioso ao invés de
beber sucos que muitas vezes concentram
o açúcar e perdem as fibras opte por
consumir a fruta inteira com casca e
bagaço quando for possível desta forma
você aproveita os benefícios
nutricionais completos da fruta
incluindo as fibras que são essenciais
para uma digestão saudável e pode ajudar
a mitigar os efeitos do açúcar no corpo
pessoal com isso em mente vamos agora
descobrir quais são essas sete frutas
que devem ser evitadas em forma de suco
ou em excesso por quem tem gordura no
fígado começamos com o cqui uma fruta
Bem deliciosa mas que seu índice
glicêmico é elevado e a carga glicêmica
é moderada pessoal para explicar melhor
o índice glicêmico indica quão rápido um
alimento eleva o açúcar no sangue
alimentos com alto índice glicêmico
elevam rapidamente fazendo com que uma
maior quantidade de insulina seja
liberada causando o chamado pico de
insulina já carga glicêmica considera
tanto a velocidade quanto a quantidade
de carboidratos do alimento medindo o
impacto total no açúcar do sangue o que
também causa o impacto no fígado por
exemplo pão brco tem alto índice
glicêmico assim como alta carga
glicêmica mas o caqui ele tem um índice
glicêmico alto e uma carga glicêmica
moderada devida a menos carboidratos por
porção então pra nossa lista estou
considerando tanto a carga quanto o
índice glicêmico no caso a quantidade de
frutose de fibras de cada fruta depois
do cqui temos a manga outra fruta
deliciosa e bem doce com índice
glicêmico de 50 e carga glicêmica de 12
alguns tipos de Mangas possuem bastante
fibras mas são bem altas em frutose para
quem tem gordura no fígado É
aconselhável limitar o consumo pessoal
abacaxxi também é fantástico mas possui
o índice glicêmico de 66 e carga
glicêmica de 14 é comum encontrar
abacaxi em saladas de frutas e sucos mas
cuidado o seu alto índice glicêmico pede
moderação prefira consumir o abacaxxi
sem que tenha amadurecido por completo
assim ele terá menos açúcar fugindo um
pouco do convencional temos as frutas
secas como damascos passas e frutas
cristalizadas cuidado com elas pessoal
Elas têm um índice glicêmico moderado
mais uma carga glicêmica bem alta Isso
significa que mesmo em pequenas
quantidades podem ter um impacto
significativo os níveis de Açúcar do
sangue já a banana é uma fruta versátil
e nutritiva com índice glicêmico de 62 e
Car glicêmica de 16 muitas pessoas
gostam de consumir bananas em vitaminas
ou com aveia diariamente no entanto para
quem tem gordura no fígado é importante
não exagerar Na quantidade e na
frequência já a melancia com índice
glicêmico alto de 72 possui uma carar
glicêmica mais baixa de sete ela é
refrescante e Apetitosa muita gente se
deixar
chega a consumir até meia melancia por
dia mas seu alto índice glicêmico e
poucas fibras pedem para que seja
consumida com cautela naqueles que TM
gordura no fígado Ok a uva
particularmente as variedades sem
semente que são extremamente doces
merecem uma atenção especial na nossa
discussão essas uvas são muito populares
e apreciadas por seu Sabor Agradável e
doçura intensa no entanto precisamos ter
cautela Especialmente quando se trata de
saúde do fígado essas uvas doces podem
ter um impacto significativo nos níveis
de glicose no sangue eu não encontrei
dados específicos sobre índice glicêmico
dessas uvas sem sementes mas sabemos que
frutas com alto teror de frutose devem
ser consumidas com moderação agora
pessoal a uva passa com índice glicêmico
de 64 e carga glicêmica de 20 é outra
fruta que devee ser consumida com muito
cuidado muitas vezes adicionada a
saladas no arroz ela pode elevar
rapidamente os níveis de açúcar no
sangue Além disso um detalhe bem
importante a ser lembrado é a maturação
das frutas quanto mais maduras elas
tiverem maior será a concentração de
Açúcar isso é especialmente relevante
para quem tem gordura no fígado então
por exemplo em vez de optar por uma
banana muito madura alternativa saudável
aqui é a banana verde na forma de
biomassa biomassa de banana verde Essa
opção não só é benéfica pro fígado mas
também oferece outros benefícios à saúde
da mesma forma ao escolher outras frutas
como abacaxxi ou manga é preferível
consumi-las quando estão levemente
começando amadurecer mas não totalmente
maduras ou já passadas evit frutas que
passaram muito do ponto de maturação
pode ser um passo simples mas sim é
eficaz para controlar a ingestão de
açúcares e cuidar melhor do seu fígado
bem a nossa comunidade de membros que
tira dúvidas comigo diretamente em lives
exclusivas semanais já aprendeu muito
sobre saúde conheça esse e outros
benefícios basta clicar aqui embaixo do
botão seja membro além das frutas que
devemos consumir com moderação há várias
opções que São mais amigas do fígado com
baixo índice de índice glicêmico baixa a
glicêmica e que podem ser incluídas
diariamente na dieta primeiro temos as
frutas vermelhas como morango framboesa
mirtilo e Amora essas frutas não apenas
TM baixo índice glicêmico mas também são
ricas em antioxidantes que ajudam na
proteção do fígado elas podem ser
consumidas em su forma natural ou mesmo
em sucos mas lembre-se sempre sem adição
de açúcares ou outros ingredientes
prejudiciais outra fruta maravilhosa pro
fígado é o açaí mas atenção Aqui estamos
falando do Açaí puro da fruta sem
adições de xaropes ou adoçantes como
normalmente é encontrado no mercado em
sorveterias o açaí na sua forma natural
é uma excelente opção a polpa do coco
também uma excelente escolha diferente
da água de coco que tem mais açúcares e
deve ser consumida com moderação a poupa
ou carne do Coco é benéfica e pode ser
incluída na dieta deve ser incluída na
dieta o limão a toranja e o maracujá são
outras frutas excelentes e que podem
ajudar na condição do fígado
especialmente o limão já a cereja em
Natura em Natura É bem interessante
porque tem índice glicêmico de 20 e cara
glicêmica de seis pessoal estou falando
da fruta cereja e não daquela imitação
de corante que vemos em potes de vidro
no Supermercados Ok por último mas não
menos importante temos o nosso campeão
abacate rico em gordura saudáveis e com
índice glicêmico de 10 carga glicêmica
de três o abacate é uma excelente opção
para incluir na sua dieta diária para
quem busca cuidar do fígado essas frutas
além de saborosas podem ser incluídas
com segurança na dieta de quem tem
gordura no fígado sempre lembrando de
consumi-las na sua forma mais natural e
com moderação pessoal é fundamental
lembrar que as frutas são componentes
essenciais de uma dieta equilibrada elas
são fontes excelentes de vitaminas
minerais e antioxidantes trazendo
inúmeros benefícios à saúde por isso
elas devem fazer parte do cotidiano
alimentar de todas as pessoas no entanto
é importante considerar que cada
indivíduo tem necessidades específicas
especialmente aqueles com condições de
saúde particulares se você não tem
nenhum problema de saúde o consumo de
frutas variada sempre com moderação é
uma prática muito saudável e
recomendável agora se você tem gordura
no fígado e pensou limitar essas frutas
para poder comer outros doces pães tomar
aquela cervejinha de milho desculpe
informar que você está se enganando se
você não mudar os hábitos alimentares de
um modo geral o seu fígado vai continuar
acumulando a gordura vai continuar
sofrendo os danos e levando a problemas
de saúde sérios e irreversíveis Então
continue comigo e assiste esses dois
vídeos relacionados são muito bons oito
comidas que destróem o seu fígado e 15
sinais na pele que revelam problemas no
fígado não deixa assistir esses dois
vídeos top estão aparecendo aí na sua
tela Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração e
você é o quê você é
feira